cuando observamos lo que llamamos fuego
esta reacción de combustión cuando vemos
estas llamas en realidad estamos
observando las tres formas de
transferencia de energía térmica
tenemos conducción
conducción también tenemos
convección
con reacción
y también tenemos radiación térmica
todas al mismo tiempo radiación
térmica
y puedo decir conducción térmica
convección térmica y radiación térmica
la palabra térmica o térmico se refiere
a la temperatura bueno donde está
ocurriendo la conducción pues la
conducción va a estar ocurriendo en el
combustible para nuestro fuego y tengo
un vídeo sobre el tema en la lista de
vídeos de química si es que están
interesados en aprender más al respecto
tomamos moléculas de carbono y sus
enlaces los cuales en la presencia de
oxígeno y calor
tendremos una reacción de combustión que
produce dióxido de carbono y que también
produce agua y genera más energía de la
que hemos puesto así que produce energía
que va a excitar a las moléculas que se
encuentran alrededor tendremos estas
moléculas con energía cinética y
recuerden que el calor no es nada más
que el promedio de energía cinética y
aquellas moléculas que estén cerca de la
combustión o sean parte de la reacción
van a tener una tremenda energía
cinética
era una energía cinética promedio muy
grande ya que toda esta energía se está
liberando debido a la reacción de
combustión y éstas a su vez van a
golpear a algunas moléculas que quizá no
tengan tanta energía cinética promedio y
se les va a transferir energía cinética
debido a estas colisiones y tenemos todo
un vídeo sobre conducción térmica y esto
es lo que pasa cosas que tienen mucha
energía cinética van a estar golpeando a
cosas que no tienen tanta energía
cinética y las van a transferir esa
energía cinética y también
transfiriéndoles momento todo esto
sucede cuando observamos un fuego como
este
moléculas que golpean a sus vecinas y
les transfieren energía cinética ahora
la convección se refiere a la idea de
que el aire caliente es menos denso
imaginemos que tenemos partículas de
aire frío aquí arriba tiene sentido que
el aire frío sea más denso que el aire
caliente ya que las partículas de aire
caliente van a tener más energía
cinética que las del aire frío por lo
que se van a golpear mucho más fuerte
entre ellas y se van a impulsar más
lejos lo que ocasionará que se separen
más entre sí y esto ocurre porque tienen
mucha energía cinética
este aire por ser menos denso vamos a
ponerlo aquí esto es
menos denso al menos comparado con el
área blanca estas moléculas son las
mismas solo estoy cambiando el color
para indicar cuál es la parte del aire
menos denso y cuál es la parte que tiene
más densidad está área menos densa se va
a elevar también pueden pensar en esto
como que el área más densa va a rodear
al área menos densa
o tratará de pasar abajo de ella ya que
es más densa así que esta área menos
densa va a ir hacia arriba
así que las moléculas más calientes van
a irse hacia arriba y las moléculas más
frías van a bajar y se van a acercar a
la fuente del calor a la fuente de
energía que está aquí para calentarse
más vamos a escribirlo
el aire caliente el aire caliente
sí
así que deja espacio para que el aire
frío baje y se caliente también
y esto es lo que ocurre en el fuego
nuestra reacción de conversión ocurre
aquí en el combustible y este aire super
caliente se va a elevar
y es por eso que las llamas nos dan la
sensación de que van hacia arriba y
también vemos algo que hablaremos un
poco más en detalle cuando veamos la
radiación térmica es que también cambia
de color conforme se eleva pero esta
idea de que las llamas se elevan y el
aire caliente también si ustedes ponen
su mano aquí va a estar mucho más
caliente que si la pusieran no sé por
ejemplo aquí aunque en teoría esto está
más cerca de la flama que esto esto
ocurre porque el aire caliente se está
elevando y está dejando espacio para que
el aire frío baje este aire frío pueda
bajar y a su vez se caliente y una vez
caliente se va a elevar otra vez así que
la convección que es el que el aire
caliente se eleve y deje espacio para
que baje el aire frío y también se
caliente esa es otra transferencia de
calor y la última forma que vemos cuando
estamos observando una llama
mencionamos que es la radiación térmica
y se refiere a la idea de que si tenemos
partículas cargadas acelerando se van a
liberar radiación electromagnética y
ustedes me pueden preguntar bueno esas
partículas cargadas con más que se están
acelerando aquí pues tenemos esas
moléculas que están siendo aceleradas
constantemente conforme están chocando
una con otra por ejemplo si esta
molécula chocara con esta le va a
transferir energía cinética y la va a
acelerar hacia otra dirección y ésta
también podría ir en otra dirección
recordemos que la aceleración es el
cambio en la velocidad podría ser la
magnitud de la velocidad o la dirección
de esa velocidad así que conforme se
golpean entre sí vamos a tener una
aceleración de estas partículas cargadas
vamos a escribirlo tenemos
aceleración
de partículas
ticul as
cargadas
la aceleración de partículas cargadas
esto libera radiación electromagnética
radiación
extra electro magnética
y ustedes me pueden decir a ver a ver un
momento puedo creer que tengamos estas
partículas que se están acelerando
porque están golpeándose unas a otras
pero de dónde salen estas partículas
cargadas esta parte de dónde viene
recordemos que estas moléculas están
hechas de átomos y los átomos están
hechos de partículas cargadas protones y
electrones y mientras más aceleramos
estas partículas cargadas más radiación
van a liberar y de nuevo me pueden decir
bueno que yo estoy observando el fuego
donde estoy observando yo esta radiación
electromagnética pues con el simple
hecho de poder ver el fuego percibimos
la radiación electromagnética la
radiación está en las ondas
electromagnéticas que nuestros ojos
interpretan como luz visible incluso las
partículas que se encuentran por acá
también están emitiendo radiación
electromagnética
ya que se están golpeando entre ellas y
sus protones y electrones se están
acelerando de diferentes formas
liberando radiación electromagnética
pero con una longitud de onda mucho más
lenta de la que puede percibir nuestros
ojos
si tuviéramos una cámara infrarroja
podríamos ver las llamas mucho más
grandes de lo que podemos verlas aquí
y si observamos el fuego con
detenimiento justamente aquí donde se
realiza la reacción de combustión la
llama es azul y la luz azul es una luz
de mayor energía y esto es porque las
partículas están siendo aceleradas mucho
más aquí y pasan del azul al blanco y
después al amarillo y después al rojo y
quizá antes del rojo o naranja y por
aquí ya no vemos nada pero aunque no lo
veamos cualquier cosa que está siendo
acelerada va a liberar radiación
electromagnética y quizá ya los convencí
de que bueno pueden ustedes observar
esto pero cómo es que se hace una
transferencia de energía o de calor con
esto pues si alguna vez se han sentado
cerca de alguna llama pueden sentir el
calor
si tuviéramos por ejemplo una llama aquí
esto es fuego y aquí hay aire frío
digamos que están en un campamento a lo
mejor este aire de aquí tiene una
temperatura de unos 13 grados celsius si
ustedes están parados aquí
aún así van a sentir el calor y esto es
porque la radiación electromagnética
está siendo emitida desde el fuego desde
las partículas de aire que percibimos
como fuego y esto puede excitar
partículas en nuestra piel transfiriendo
energía a nuestra piel por lo que
podemos sentir que nos estamos
calentando recuerdo una ocasión en la
que yo iba conduciendo en la carretera y
había un auto accidentado que se estaba
quemando y yo estaba como a tres
carriles de distancia de ese auto porque
pues estaba accidentado y en el momento
en el que estaba yo pasando el auto
explotó y de inmediato sentí una onda de
calor a pesar de que yo tenía arriba el
vidrio yo espero que nadie estuviera
dentro de ese coche cuando explotó pero
el calor que sentí después de la
explosión fue debido a la radiación
electromagnética una radiación térmica
que es liberada por esas partículas
excitadas en él
aire alrededor de la explosión que
nosotros percibimos como una explosión
un fuego pero realmente era la
excitación de las partículas en mi piel
debido a la radiación